just before we get into today's video i
do want to give a random
youtube plug sometimes i'm browsing
around on youtube and i'll stumble
across a channel that i think is
criminally under
subscribed and that channel that i'd
like to tell you about today is called
dumb
money we are dumb money we quit our day
jobs to do this
i'm going to check out the closest
cannabis dispensaries you're into this
sort of stuff the political and
economic thing this is more
business-focused channel
i'm not getting paid to say this or
anything like that it's just a channel
that i stumbled across
i really like it's got a few thousand
subscribers and i'd like to send them
some more so
that is what this is about you'll find
them linked to below
just go check it out and let's get on
with it
nobody likes dictators but what happens
when the alternative
is even worse well this is the story of
libya this
is the story of former prime minister
gaddafi's rise
and his fall
[Applause]
[Music]
libya has more oil reserves than america
in fact they have the biggest oil
reserves in africa
then again production wise they are far
below most of the famous oil countries
even below iran despite trump's
sanctions
[Music]
why well maybe you've heard of the arab
spring after that period of uprisings
and general destabilization
libya is the country that ended up the
worst off
basically there's a lesson to be learned
from libya and that's that no matter how
bad you think a country might be doing
it can always be doing worse
maybe you've seen the movie the dictator
by sacha baron cohen
well this parody was pretty much
inspired by
gaddafi
[Music]
indeed he is one of the craziest
dictators of all time
and he ruled libya for decades gadhafi
was well known for having his own harem
of about 30 women
this harem was known as the amazonian
guard
from the early 1970s onwards they
remained close at his side at all times
sometimes the women even took bullets
for gadhafi one woman died and
two were injured when the libyan leader
was attacked in 1998.
some of the conditions to become part of
the guard were to make an oath of
virginity
dressing camouflage and maintain perfect
nail polish and makeup
of course there are thousands of reports
of rape and abuse that came to light
after gaddafi's death
surprisingly during his lifetime gadhafi
always congratulated himself as
a protector of women's rights in the
arab world
but not only that the self-proclaimed
brother leader had
a massive fear of heights and could not
fly more than eight hours over water
he also had some peculiar demands when
he stayed in hotels he always had to
stay on the first floor and he would not
climb more than 35 steps
so yes if we make a video ranking the
most extravagant dictators of all time
qadhafi would certainly be in our top
10. diplomacy wise gaddafi is one of
those dictators that went from being
america's worst enemy to
a friend of the us before becoming yet
again the man america loved to hate
and today libya is a chaotic state where
even foreign oil companies have to make
deals with warlords in order to keep
pumping oil
don't believe me well just have a look
at this news
repsol oil fields in libya go back to
business after deal with raiders
in this case a spanish oil company
repsol had an agreement with the libyan
national oil corporation in 2008.
back then they just had to agree with
the dictatorship in order to do business
then during the libyan civil war a
different warlord took over repsol
facilities
and finally after a lot of struggle in
2018 the oil company had to make an
agreement
with a local tribe so what happened here
what's going on in libya
today and why would an oil company make
a deal with a warlord well today we're
going to answer all of these questions
but before we do
let's take a look back at the history
[Music]
the man you love to hate have you ever
seen the movie
naked gun it starts with a scene where
gaddafi appears next to the other bad
guys of the moment idiom
in ayatollah khamenei gorbachev yasser
arafat fidel castro
they're all gathered in this room and
they're making a plan to defeat the
united states
yes dear viewer that was a time when
gaddafi was considered to be one of the
worst evils on the planet
why well let's take a look back in time
libya was an italian colony for several
decades in the early 1900s then it
became
a monarchy until in 1969 gaddafi rose to
power
he believed in so-called arab socialism
a strange cocktail of
centralized economy secularism and cult
of personality
he even developed his own political
philosophy writing an extremely
influential book
the green book he made countless
appearances at arab and
international gatherings standing out
not just with his outlandish clothing
but also because of his blunt speeches
and odd behavior even some socialist
parties in europe were sponsored by him
the reality was that oil could pay for a
lot of influence in the rest of the
world
[Music]
but unlike other countries like egypt he
didn't nationalize oil he put harder
conditions on foreign oil companies but
that was all he challenged our
executives by stating people who have
lived without oil for five thousand
years can
live without it again for a few years in
order to attain
their legitimate rights that was a bold
move a move that helped him secure a
majority share of oil company revenues
while at the same
time maintaining an effective oil
industry in the country
despite the socialism and the
dictatorship libya was still open for
business
repsol says libyan oil nationalization
unlikely and let's be honest here the
formula worked
many european companies like eni total
and repsol kept
doing business with libya money came on
money went in
oil came out and the country's citizens
they benefited
for years libya had the highest human
development index of any african country
at certain points it even surpassed
south africa this
all was accompanied by a very
controversial foreign policy
during the 1980s and 1990s gaddafi
aligned himself with the eastern bloc
fidel castro's cuba and openly supported
movements like the irish republican army
and the palestinian liberation front but
none of this
would have been a big deal if it wasn't
for the terrorism
libya's government was known to
participate or aid in terrorist attacks
many marxist-inspired guerrilla groups
or even terrorist groups were funded by
gaddafi but the defining moment was the
bombing of a nightclub in berlin where
american soldiers used to frequent many
libyan spies were involved in this and
america didn't wait to answer seven
o'clock this evening eastern time
air and naval forces of the united
states launched a series of strikes
against the headquarters
terrorist facilities and military assets
that support muammar qaddafi's
subversive activities
the harsh reaction was supposed to kill
the mad dog of the middle east as
reagan branded gaddafi but the colonel
came out of the attack unscathed
america put libya on the terrorist
friendly countries list and american
companies were restricted from
exploiting all there
nonetheless those european countries
like total repsol and
eni they kept on doing their thing
in libya repsol works in one of the
biggest oil baths discovered lately
with over a billion fruit boundaries
this is the power of all
[Music]
petroleum but let's press on forward
with our story in 2001 9 11 happened and
this was a turning point for gaddafi's
foreign policy
[Music]
terrorist-loving as he was gadhafi was
inspired by socialism
not by radical islam therefore osama bin
laden was a common enemy both of america
and many socialist leaders this is how
gaddafi started collaborating with
america he
signed a nuclear disarmament agreement
in which the leader agreed to eliminate
his country's nuclear weapons
the u.s declared victory and everything
else was good again in 2006 they even
took libya off the list of terrorist
countries
gaddafi he was a son of a [ __ ] but you
know
at least he was now bar son of a [ __ ]
nonetheless
again things changed in 2011.
the arab spring the arab spring began in
december of 2010 when mohammed boazizi a
tunisian street vendor set himself on
fire
in protest against the police he could
never have imagined how his sacrifice
would spark a revolution all of a sudden
the tunisian people started protesting
against their governments which
was another arab socialist dictatorship
and this
it inspired protesters in neighboring
countries suddenly
most of the northern african countries
they were overthrowing their dictators
libya was not an exception and in 2011 a
civil war broke out
when the first winds of rebellion
started blowing towards libya gaddafi
even tried to
protest with the people trying to keep
up with his brother leader of the
revolution image that
he was so desperate to cling on to but
turns out
people could see through this the scent
of freedom
it was inebriating many young libyans
were fueled by the recent toppling of
egypt's mubarak and tunisia's benelli
that's when gaddafi changed his tune and
reverted back to being
ruthless
[Music]
gaddafi tells the media all my people
love me
they would die to protect me libyan
leader laughs off international pressure
to step down while speaking to news
organizations
within days opposition supporters were
controlling benghazi and the government
were seeing
massive rates of defection the rebels
tried organizing even further but they
were being hit pretty hard by the
colonel's forces
as you can imagine qadhafi had an army
much bigger than
those 30 women from his amazon guard
libyan oil had also helped pay for a lot
of modern weaponry
and this was pretty helpful in
repressing protesters
[Music]
but so many people lost their lives the
image of qadhafi outside of libya
it simply couldn't get worse once again
he went from being our bad guy to the
man everyone loved to hate and
this is why a coalition led by nato
forces invaded libya on the 21st of
march 2011
in support of the rebels
[Music]
but it was months before nato could turn
the tables as the fighting intensified
nato carried out a bombing campaign in
support of anti-gaddafi forces
the bombing forced gaddafi to flee from
tripoli to his hometown of cert
where opposition fighters would
eventually capture him
on october 20th 2011 a video released by
the fighters shows gaddafi begging for
his life
in another clip the former strong man is
seen dead with an apparent gunshot wound
to the head
muammar gaddafi was caught and shot dead
by the militias of the libyan national
transitional council with the
active support of french intelligence
many of you might be tempted to say sick
tempered taranis right
but hold on just a minute
[Music]
from bad to even worse after the corpse
of the former dictator was dragged
through the streets and
put on display the rebels turned on each
other the country it was split and
crime and human trafficking ran rampant
and if there's one rule in politics
it is this there cannot be a power
vacuum gaddafi was gone but who or what
was the alternative even though some
western countries had been doing good
business with gaddafi they
never fully trusted him
they saw the civil war as an opportunity
to remove him from power and
intervene militarily in order to cut off
the arab revolution that had
flared up in tunisia and egypt it also
provided powers such as france and
britain a chance to reassert
themselves on the world stage after
gaddafi's death libya was
torn up and divided without a national
government to claim control
and what that meant at the time was that
local militias had the power of
life and death over the population the
economy was also
pretty messed up as one might expect
after a revolution the gdp collapsed in
and in 2015 the production of crude oil
fell to the
lowest levels since the 1970s
ex-nato boss libya still a model
intervention you see unlike the iraq or
afghanistan war the libyan one was a
different animal
in this case it was not led by america
but instead
by france and the french military style
it couldn't be more different
usually the americans invade a country
kill the dictator and then stay there
for a few
years we've seen this in japan and in
germany after world war ii but
also later in iraq and afghanistan the
military tries to make sure that
they can form a post-war government and
fight the last groups that supported the
former one the french they're pretty
much the opposite
they strike they kill the bad guy and
they get out of there this is what
happened in mali for example and
this is what happened in libya so
effectiveness wise the libyan war was a
complete success
in fact if you look at this chart you
can see that it was one of the cheapest
wars in modern history it took only a
little more than a month to complete
compared with iraq or afghanistan the
libyan war couldn't be
more cost effective
[Music]
so well what's the problem well of
course that's the aftermath
after the fall of qaddafi three main
players emerged in the country the
government of tripoli
supported by turkey and qatar the
government of tabruk supported mainly by
egypt and the united arab emirates
and last but not least daesh forces
war raged once more and daesh took
advantage of the chaos and expanded
rapidly the elections in 2014 were
marred by
violence and low turnout eventually a
compromise was found and a government of
national agreement it was formed
supported by the u.n
a group that monitors violence using
media reports estimated that more than 4
600 people have died in the fighting
since the beginning
of 2014 and the u.n estimates that 2.44
million people about a third of libya's
population have been affected by the
fighting which
has led to shortages of food water
electricity
and medical supplies and it's also
reduced access to healthcare and public
services
forgotten war a crisis deepens in libya
but where are the cameras
as you might have noticed libya isn't
doing much better today the government
installed in 2016 only has
a partial hold on the country given this
instability there are no facilities and
desert patrols to tackle
trafficking networks there are also no
funds for libya's coast guard to
monitor sea crossings and this is why in
this dangerous power vacuum
oil companies are even starting to make
deals with local tribes in order to keep
their businesses going
[Music]
the repsol camp in libya resumes
activity
after agreement with the assailants
despite all the turmoil repsol is still
going strong in libya and is currently
preparing to increase production even
more
money it seems really does talk now the
question is
if even big oil companies are making
deals with rebels does a unified libyan
government
really have a chance i mean will we ever
see a democratic and stable government
in this country
well please leave your answers to that
in the comment section below
and of course please don't forget to
visit our friends from reconsider
media.com the podcast that provided the
vocals in this episode that are not mine
also remember we publish brand new
videos every week so subscribe to
visualpolitik
and hit that bell button so you won't
miss out on any posts if you like this
video
give it a like also check out dumb money
who i mentioned at the beginning of this
video find a link to them below
and as always i'll see you next time and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider media.com
podcast see you there